NEIGHBORS TO THESI OFASUN  RISE
MANAGED TOEELOW AND STEADY. NO?
>> Reporter: SO, I
PREFACE ALL, BROOKE, AND
U U' IT
THAT THERE ARE SOPLE DIDN'DO RI.
IT IS A DLL T
D
A KEY DIFFEREE.D ME FOL VIRUSN
FO CANADA IT'HOTH WAVID PATIENT
CURVMBED, CANADA CRUSHED
ITNOWSEEINGAVAGEWAY
TH
AND Y NO ONE ISSSION ACCOMPLIED
>> THEON HIGHLIGHTSR US IEE
'RAIOLIGILANCE H B
EAYIDPRSTILLG SURGE CAPACIT AND
NT >> I WEAR IT FOR MYSELF AND
OTRS
PREKOMHEPECTABLERESPECTABLE TO E
TR EARLY SYSTEM
AND PROVEING IT COU B
>> AOT IECOHESIVENESS,
INFORMATION PPL NEEDED TO TO
DO WHATHDED THO D THADP INTO OPG
AGAIN.PE
THE BASICRY
KEEP EACH OTHE
>> Reporter: SHE POIO
TH CRITIL, OUT OF THE RECONSERV
PRDE WHAT CAN S?ABION RE ALL
COMINGOG THE
EOE ANDHE
HT DECISIONSBAED ALSO.S./CANADA
AMANE TOO, MHAD TRICMOREN IED.
TOFFED
SENIORES>> I DON'T REMEMBER ANY
T
>> Reporter: PIS
TRUDEAU IT'SALS TO WS. IMATH
YO H3,0  WHAT CTA.
YO.
YOU CANP ATE THEM. I ISADA KNEWI
A